so recently twitch was served a twenty
five million dollar lawsuit by a guy
dealing with a severe sex addiction
basically he believes that the hundreds
of women's streamers he follows makes
his sex addiction worse and it's all
Twitch's fault yeah this story is as
crazy as it sounds let's get into it
alright guys we're streaming over at
twitch TV slash the score eSports and
we're adding more and more content every
single week so whether it's our talk
show clouded or the rotating Friday
streams follow the channel so you know
when we go live and maybe you'll catch
me winning another absurd game of chess
there you go yes i won
wait what what kind of stupid game
honestly I don't know how the [ __ ] that
happened okay now back to the lawsuit on
June 15th a guy named Eric esta Villa
filed a twenty five million dollar
lawsuit against twitch lawsuit states
that esta Villa suffers from a bunch of
health issues including OCD depression
and a severe sex addiction and the
lawsuit goes on to say that quote
because of these maladies he heavily
relies on the internet for all of his
entertainment purposes and basically
he's suing twitch because he alleges
that women twitch streamers make his sex
addiction in OCD worse quote twitch has
severely exacerbated his condition by
displaying many sexually suggestive
women streamers through twitches twisted
programming and net code making it
nearly impossible for the plaintiff to
use twitch without being exposed to such
sexually suggestive content end quote to
be clear and this is in the lawsuit s
tobillo follows exactly 786 women's
streamers in exactly zero mail streamers
not only does the lawsuit name twenty
popular women streamers including
illinit e and polkie main it includes
pages and pages of photos of these women
as evidence and as I was going through
this lawsuit looking through these
photos it just felt really weird it
didn't sit right with me one other issue
that esta Villa says exacerbates his sex
addiction is the fact that you can't
choose to break down streams by gender
quote there's no way for the plaintiff
to filter streams he'd like to watch
based on gender male or female
therefore the plaintiff has to choose a
game and/or category to watch with
thumbnails showing these scantily clad
women alongside men of being the only
streaming channels available to him
now in reality you could manually filter
between men and women streamers
depending on who you follow but remember
according to the lawsuit esta Villa
follows exactly 786 women streamers and
zero men again according to the lawsuit
the 25 million dollars that esta billow
is asking for is to be split between him
and other twitch prime turbo subscribers
with the rest of the money leftover
going to charities of the courts
choosing on top of the 25 million esta
Villa was asking twitch to permanently
ban the 20 women named in the lawsuit
okay everything we just discussed makes
up the front half of the lawsuit the
entire back half of a lawsuit is
dedicated to multiple academic papers
breaking down the history and research
done on sex addiction and listen this is
a real medical issue and this guy
deserves all the help that he needs but
blaming women on twitch is probably not
the answer here now if you're thinking
where the hell did this come from
well actually esta villo has a history
of filing these kind of over-the-top
lawsuits it all starts back in 2009
after esta Villa was banned from PSN for
being a troll while playing resistance
fall of man online and if you didn't
know PSN is basically Playstations
online ecosystem similar to Xbox Live
here's a quote from an interview he did
with an gadget when he originally filed
the lawsuit quote i sued Sony because
when they banned me they banned my whole
console which is like a $500 waste there
because I can't go online anymore which
was one of my ways of socializing so
when I sued for fifty five thousand
dollars that was something called
punitive damages when you're trying to
penalize a company and that's what I was
trying to do penalize them for banning
someone end quote from there he sued
Sony again Plus Microsoft in Nintendo's
over flaws in different console designs
that he purposely tried to find then in
2010 IGN GameSpot Kotaku and a bunch of
other gaming websites did their job and
wrote about the lawsuits that s tobillo
had filed against Sony Microsoft and
Nintendo and he really didn't like that
like as in he filed one giant lawsuit
against 13 different websites because he
was upset about the fact that they were
writing about him esta bellow became
so notorious that he was given all sorts
of nicknames the PSN plaintiff the
serial sewer the list goes on also he
once sued blizzard because apparently
walking in World of Warcraft took too
long and in the lawsuit he tried to rope
in actress Winona Ryder to quote explain
the significance of alienation in
Catcher in the Rye end quote
Winona Ryder Catcher in the Rye World of
Warcraft what and you probably won't be
surprised to hear that all eight
lawsuits were either dropped by a
Stabilo himself or dismissed by the
court out right now the complaint
against twitch was filed on June 15th
while the summons was served to them on
June 19th
meaning legally now they have to respond
in court and while twitch hasn't made an
official statement on this situation
it's only a matter of time before the
court proceedings become public and hey
maybe this case will go farther than
anyone else was expecting I'm not trying
to zag just because everybody else is
going in one direction but I honestly
don't understand a lot of the complaints
like people are really upset about the
story choices and and things like that
and it's just like why why are you upset
that somebody told you a story that you
didn't agree with the choices like it's
not your [ __ ] story to tell and I get
that we have connections to characters
and when certain things happen it makes
you upset but really III fundamentally
do not understand how people can be
upset about somebody else's narrative
that they've created and written